hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the magnus carlson
invitational knockouts
we are in the first day of the
semi-finals and this is the other match
wesley so versus anishigiri and
this is game four so the match started
uh well definitely in wesley's favor
wesley won the first game then the
second game ended in the draw
and then gary was able to equalize in
the third game so this is game four and
the everything is hanging on this game
well not the result of the
semi-finals as there will be another day
of four games
uh but uh definitely a lot so here
wesley has the white pieces
and uh well enjoyed this one so wesley
opens with
d4 and we have knight to f6 by geary we
have c4 uh we have g6 knight to c3 and
d5 so just a standard uh groomfield
defense here
and now bishop to f4 so something
that's uh used to avoid any sort of
uh as as i'm aware of uh
complications in the groomfield uh we
have bishop to g7
and now we have e3 uh we have castles by
black the so-called grunfeld gambit
uh and this is basically giving up a
pawn but it's
very dangerous to actually it's not
dangerous for for black in me
in in the sense of maybe he's going to
get into a lot of trouble when you're
playing against someone like giri
uh who knows uh mo probably everything
by heart
uh the problem is if you go for the pawn
with something like uh
with c captures on the five knight
characters knight captures and queen
captures yes white can capture on c7
uh but it's gonna be uh well the black
the white king is still in the center of
the board and maybe
not something you want to do in a rapid
game and uh i think
out of out of all the lines that uh come
out of this position
the this one has the highest drawing
percentage so here
uh the ways you can uh avoided this
gruntful gambit is something like queen
b3 rook to c1 knight to f3
and so on and here wesley goes rook to
c1 he doesn't wanna any sort of a quick
draw because this is game four
everything is hanging on this game
and he has the white pieces so of course
he wants to keep
you know everything on the board and
play a play a series game
so rook to c1 this is the top move in
the position
and now bishop to e6 by geary uh we have
c5 wesley grabs more space on the queen
side
now with ideas of maybe b for a4 in the
future and now
c6 this is the standard idea when
someone plays uh
a move like c5 later on you want to
undermine it with moves like b6 and if
b4 then even a5
uh so bishop to d3 was the continuous
development and
now bishop to g4 getting the
bishop uh out of that e6 square so you
can strike
with with e6 or e5 uh depending on the
position so here knight g to e2
and there is one given the database uh a
fine top tier game from the
2015 build tournament between raz
lavoitech and maxime vashilagrav where
maxine played rook to e8
but maxime lost that game uh so here
instead we have b6
by giri and it is only now as of move 9
that we have a completely new game
so let's see uh how uh you deal with
this usually when uh black
tries to undermine your pawn chain
you're gonna play some like b4 and then
if a5 a3
uh but here wesley instead goes knight
to a4 he says okay if you capture here
i'm just gonna get a beautiful outpost
uh
for my knight on c5 so here knight f to
d7
adding another attacker to the c5 pawn
and now f3
finally chasing back the bishop but now
you don't really have a good square for
the bishop
because well you can't go here or g4
just traps your bishop and you
the knight is kind of blocking your way
so here gary goes for e5 this was the
plan all along and now
at the point is the the dark square
bishop of whites is under attack and if
you move it only then will
remove his bishop back to e6 uh without
uh
blocking his pawn that was still on e7
but instead
after this e5 wesley says okay i accept
your challenge
bishop captures on e5 we have knight
captures on e5 and
now d captures on e5 so the bishop is
still under attack
gary has to move it bishop back to c8
and now wesley
plays f4 and gets this very uh strong
setup in the center here
so f6 uh first you undermine the pawn
chain on the queen side now you do so in
the center that's how you have to
destroy pawn chains we have e captures
and f6 queen captures
and now uh we have king side castles by
wesley and if you look at the position
now
uh it's a pretty fine position for both
of them maybe black is to be preferred a
little bit i have no idea
but the the knight here is a bit oddly
placed you have a backwards pawn on e3
that could become a target so
i don't know uh even though the engine
is uh very unclear here
uh it seems i don't know black seems to
be uh perfectly
fine here so instead okay we have queen
to e7 going immediately after that
weakness on e3 and now queen to d2
defending we
rook the e8 geary piles up on the e3
pawn
and now rook to f3 defending it once
more and now
bishop to g4 so this is all very very
standard we have rook to g3 still
keeping an eye on the e3 pawn
and the geary traits here we have bishop
captures bishop captures and
knight to d7 so um a very
very quick uh trade in order to uh
well finish your development uh so here
b4
uh cementing that pawn on c5 and now
knight to f6 the knight now can come to
e4 and that would be deadly because the
rook and the queen would be under attack
so knight to c3 you have to bring it
back to control the
uh e4 square and now b cap presidency
five
b captures and rook a to d8 and if you
look at the position now
uh although the uh you know it could be
equal in engines terms but for
for a human it does appear like black is
the one uh
putting all the pressure on the position
because of this weak uh backwards pawn
uh and here it's not easy to find a move
for white white it doesn't uh have an
active move in this position white
needs to play a waiting move something
like bishop to d3 for example
uh and then black has all sorts of move
black and play rook to b8 black and
strike in the center with d4
black can even grab a pawn on c5 that's
the kind of the idea and if you if you
go for something like this then let's
say knight d2 opens up the attack
towards the queen
queen moves and then maybe you can
continue playing this being down upon
but it's not an easy position for white
so wesley instead and he was very long
on time here i think
gary was down to some maybe two and a
half minutes wesley was down to 30
seconds
wesley strikes in the center with f5 and
we finally reached the position from the
thumbnail
and as the title suggests uh you know
you've heard f6 is bad but
i mean uh f5 can also be pretty bad and
this f5 is kind of losing on the spot so
feel free to pause the video here and to
win the game for gary uh while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
finding the uh this elusive idea and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's bishop to h6 bishop to h6 and
the white can resign there really is no
good move here
bishop captures on e3 is coming and
that's just it
there's no way to defend the pawn one
way to defend it is to move the knights
to d1 but if we do that
then we no longer defend e4 square so if
you play knight to d1 knight to e4 and
then
white just loses material and that's it
there's uh no point in continuing this
so here i had to get replayed bishop to
h6 it would be
i think a quick resign for wesley uh
there is some
uh counter play here with some moves
like f captures and g6 but this is only
only for fun it's it's not really doing
anything for example bishop captures
here
uh delivering check rook captures and
then
or queen captures and then we can trade
everything off captures captures
captures captures and captures
and then you can get one more capture
here and after king captures
we get to this position where okay maybe
you can play this but
it would be uh of course um a a very
easy win for black
maybe if not for the for the past deep
on but it's uh
completely winning for black so although
it's possible
uh it doesn't really matter because
geary did not play it gary instead
said okay thank you for the free pawn
gary just grabbed the pawn
and like i said wesley was a very long
time so gary didn't want to spend too
much time
trying to find a better move because he
knew the the extra pawn was
uh probably winning so why not you know
save time
so here rook to f1 wesley will now try
to organize some sort of an attack and
now
knight to e4 getting the knight to this
beautiful outpost and forcing a trade
because now the queen and rook are under
attack
so knight captures f captures and now
bishop to g4
uh we have rook to f8 and now gary just
of course wants to trade
and bishop to f5 now avoiding the trade
and preparing the queen to enter the
game
we have rook to f6 now preparing to
double up on the f file
and the queen to e2 now preparing queen
to h5 so queen to f7 stopping that
and wesley still brings the queen in
with queen to g4
we have rooked the f8 giving out triples
up on the f file
and now rook to f2 so what you play here
there are a couple of moves you could
play but some of them could be wrong so
be very careful feel free to pause the
video here
and find the only winning move for gary
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
just unpinning and for those who just
want to enjoy the show
king the h8 is the only winning move you
have to get the king
away from that g file to give you an
example if you try a weird move let's
say you play something like a5 just uh
get
uh an idea of what the threat is the the
threat is bishop to e6 and
white wins the problem is uh if you
capture
the bishop with the rook then just rook
captures here and that's it whatever you
capture with
uh just either rook characters or queen
characters here uh or if king captures
them the queen captures bishop and
black is completely doomed another thing
after uh ideas like uh this uh
uh uh after this uh bishop to e6 is to
capture
with the queen right away but then it's
just checkmate in one queen captures on
g7 is checkmate
so you have to be careful uh wesley's
rook to f2 is basically a waiting move
uh but also if you know the posit the
bishop kind of moves rook captures on f2
will not be checkmated whereas rook
captures on f1 would be checkmate
so kind of a waiting move but giri
doesn't fall for it gear he finds the
winning idea he plays king to h8
and now wesley still continues with
bishop to e6 but it is not enough
uh so here queen to e7 giri just gets
the queen out of harm's way now the rook
is hanging here
so bishop back to f5 but now bishop to
h6
and now you don't really have a a good
move here
uh rook the h3 was played but now queen
to e5
again with a triple attack on the bishop
but also going after the a1 square
and here wesley tried defending that a1
square rook to f1 but now just
rook captures on f5 and it seems like
wesley will be able to win back the
piece because rook captures an h6
but not really uh we have rook captures
on f5 we have rook captures on f5 and he
was in this position that uh wesley so
resigned the game
and anish giri wins game four which
means that he also wins the first match
the first match problem is if you
capture this then it's a mate in two
quintet one check the king has no
squares you have to block with the queen
and then queen captures on d1
is checkmate so after rook captures an
f5
uh whistler resigned and a very nice
victory and only 36 moves for anish
geary
so as you've seen uh you know it was a
pretty crazy
pretty crazy game uh giri was playing a
very very very safe line then
wesley of course declined to play for uh
unknown uh
maybe drawish line with the white pieces
he wanted to take his chances but then
he started spending too much time and
this
gear is extremely solid it all went down
to this
position where wesley tried to open up
something for the attack with this f5
move and then
uh you know it it just didn't work so
this is one of those positions where
you know the engine will tell you that
yeah that's perfectly fine maybe you can
play it and you can hold it but in a
rapid game
i i mean if you look at it it's uh
definitely definitely all black because
black's moves are
some somewhat intuitive and you can find
them whereas the white's moves are you
know
pretty much uh forced waiting moves so i
don't know it's kind of
kind of difficult to play positions like
that uh but yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
we'll see what happens so uh
johnny point she defeated magnus carlsen
in the first match magnus we'll need to
bounce back
to data get back and we'll see what
happens on day two and who will
uh meet in the finals of the magnus
crossing invitational
uh so i hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank mr hoodie guy pete's
cowon robert jackness uh nicholas uh
bulokos and connor watts for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the magnus
carlsen invitational checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world uh so thank y'all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day